This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you've spent any amount of time driving through any major American city, you know what it's like to be stuck in bumper-to-bumper traffic. The experience of crawling along, listening to people honking, and feeling your soul leaving your body. But no one, no one understands this pain better than someone from Los Angeles. I got stuck in traffic on the 101 freeway through Hollywood, and I was thinking to myself,
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你曾在任何美国大城市开车，你一定体会过陷入车流、动弹不得的感觉。那种缓慢爬行、听着人们鸣笛、感觉灵魂出窍的经历。但没有人，真的没有人比洛杉矶人更懂这种痛苦。我曾被困在好莱坞的101号高速公路上，当时我心想：
what am I doing behind this guy in a Jeep with too many bumper stickers, and why hasn't my car moved for half an hour? This is Jake Berman. He used to live in LA. So he understands this struggle all too well. But as Jake discovered, it didn't have to be this way. I found a very old map that was put out as publicity by the old Pacific Electric Railway that
我为什么要跟在这辆贴满保险杠贴纸的吉普车后面？为什么我的车半小时都没动一下？这是杰克·伯曼。他曾住在洛杉矶，所以他非常了解这种挣扎。但正如杰克所发现的，情况本不必如此。我找到了一张非常古老的地图，那是老太平洋电气铁路公司为了宣传而发布的，
owned this massive electric railway system. And as part of their advertising, they had in huge letters the massive electric railway system. And as part of their advertising, they had in huge letters the largest electric railway system in the world. And this flipped a switch in my head because this is Los Angeles. What Jay quickly learned is that LA hasn't always been the car-centric city we know today.
他们拥有一个庞大的电气铁路系统。作为广告的一部分，他们用巨大的字体写着“世界上最庞大的电气铁路系统”。这让我脑中灵光一现，因为这里可是洛杉矶。杰克很快了解到，洛杉矶并不总是我们今天所知的这种以汽车为中心的城市。
It was home to a massive public transit network. At one time, Los Angeles, of all places, the land of freeways, traffic, and smog, had an electric railway system that was four times the size of the modern London Underground. So I was thinking to myself, what happened here? And so as I went down the rabbit hole, I found that this was the common story in North America,
它曾经拥有一个庞大的公共交通网络。曾几何时，洛杉矶这个高速公路、交通拥堵和雾霾之地，竟然拥有一个规模是现代伦敦地铁四倍的电气铁路系统。所以我心想，这里到底发生了什么？随着我深入挖掘，我发现这是北美普遍存在的故事，
like nowhere else in the world, that the United States and Canada, to a lesser extent, abandoned mass transit in a way that other industrialized countries didn't. This experience inspired Jake to write The Lost Subways of North America, a book about the subways of our past, present, and future, and why public transit in so many of our cities fall way short of our needs. In his book, Jake doesn't just write about subways. He also looks at buses, streetcars, commuter rail, and basically all types of urban public transportation. And he says that for public transit to work in any city, it needs to have four main characteristics.
世界上其他地方绝无仅有，美国和加拿大在某种程度上放弃了大众交通，而其他工业化国家却没有这样做。这段经历启发杰克写下了《北美的失落地铁》，这是一本关于我们过去、现在和未来的地铁的书，探讨了为什么我们许多城市的公共交通远不能满足需求。在书中，杰克不仅写了地铁，他还研究了公共汽车、有轨电车、通勤铁路，以及基本上所有类型的城市公共交通。他说，要让公共交通在任何城市发挥作用，它需要具备四个主要特征。
That is, for anyone to actually use it. A functioning transit system is fast, frequent, reliable, and it goes places people want to go. So there are four ways to do it right. According to Jake, though, there are many, many ways to do it right. According to Jake, though, there are many, many ways to do it wrong. I like to think it's like that old line of tollstoys. All happy transit systems are alike. Each unhappy transit system is unhappy in its own way. Right. So in Miami, for instance, they have a metro system that is fast, frequent and reliable,
也就是说，要让人真正去使用它。一个有效的交通系统必须是快速、频繁、可靠的，并且要能到达人们想去的地方。所以有四种方法可以做好。但根据杰克的说法，也有很多很多方法会把它搞砸。我喜欢用托尔斯泰的那句名言来类比：所有幸福的交通系统都是相似的，每个不幸的交通系统则各有各的不幸。没错。比如在迈阿密，他们有一个快速、频繁且可靠的地铁系统，
but it doesn't go the places that people want to go, so very few people take the train. In Philadelphia, they have a really excellent regional rail system run by SEPTA, which is the name of the Transit Authority, and it goes all the places that people want to go. It is fast, it is reliable, but they only run one train an hour, which makes a big difference in whether people are willing to take transit or not. it is reliable, but they only run one train an hour, which makes a big difference in whether people are willing to take transit or not. The truth is, many North America's subway systems aren't just unhappy,
但它不去人们想去的地方，所以很少有人坐火车。在费城，他们有一个由SEPTA（交通管理局的名称）运营的非常出色的区域铁路系统，它能到达人们想去的所有地方。它快速、可靠，但他们每小时只发一班车，这对于人们是否愿意乘坐公共交通有着巨大的影响。事实是，许多北美的地铁系统不仅是不幸的，
they are profoundly miserably disappointing. Because it's not like North American cities haven't been trying to match the transit systems that you see in places like Western Europe or Japan. In fact, Jake's book points to time after time when we seem to be just inches away from a robust, utopian future of fast, frequent, reliable, and convenient trains, only to have one thing or a combination of things get in the way. So all unhappy transit systems are unhappy
而且是令人深感失望的。因为这并不是说北美城市没有尝试过匹配你在西欧或日本等地看到的交通系统。事实上，杰克的书一次又一次地指出，我们似乎离一个快速、频繁、可靠且便捷的列车乌托邦未来只有几英寸之遥，却总被一件事或几件事的组合所阻碍。所以所有不幸的交通系统都是不幸的，
in their own ways, but their particular failures and what we can learn from them point to ways that maybe, just maybe, our cities can get the subways of our dreams. Jake and I are gonna go through a handful of North American cities and discuss what went wrong to find out what exactly makes or breaks a transit system. Starting with the red car of Los Angeles.
各有各的不幸，但它们的具体失败以及我们能从中吸取的教训，指出了我们的城市或许、仅仅是或许，能够拥有我们梦想中的地铁。杰克和我将浏览一些北美城市，讨论哪里出了问题，以找出究竟是什么决定了一个交通系统的成败。从洛杉矶的“红车”开始。
When Jake found the map that launched his research, what he was looking at was the route of LA's red car. Longtime 99PI listeners might remember our 2013 episode, The Great Red Car Conspiracy. In the early 1900s, the red car got Angelino's where they wanted to go. It was a system of electric street trolleys that connected seaside towns and suburban neighborhoods to downtown LA. In its heyday, there were more than 2,100 trains running every day across over a thousand miles of track. And the reason many Angelino's today have never even heard of the red car has to do with monopoly,
当杰克找到那张开启他研究的地图时，他看到的是洛杉矶“红车”的路线。99PI的资深听众可能还记得我们2013年的那一集《伟大的红车阴谋》。在20世纪初，“红车”把洛杉矶人送到了他们想去的地方。这是一个由电动有轨电车组成的系统，连接着海滨城镇、郊区社区和洛杉矶市中心。在鼎盛时期，每天有超过2100列火车在超过一千英里的轨道上运行。而今天许多洛杉矶人甚至从未听说过“红车”，这与垄断有关，
maintenance and the greed of a 20th century robber baron named Henry Huntington. Henry Huntington and his company Pacific Electric built the electric railway system that was the largest and most impressive in the world at the time. But ironically enough, railways were not actually how Pacific Electric made most of its money. In the United States and Canada, it was very common and quite frankly the norm for ostensibly a train company to have another line of business where they made their real money. So in Seattle, it was Seattle Electric. In Atlanta, it was Georgia Power, which still is the power company in Atlanta that ran the trains because those two businesses worked together really well at the time. If you wanted to electrify a
与维护有关，也与一位名叫亨利·亨廷顿的20世纪强盗大亨的贪婪有关。亨利·亨廷顿和他的太平洋电气公司建造了当时世界上最大、最令人印象深刻的电气铁路系统。但讽刺的是，铁路实际上并不是太平洋电气公司赚钱的主要方式。在美国和加拿大，一家表面上的火车公司拥有另一条真正赚钱的业务线是非常普遍的，坦率地说，这甚至是常态。在西雅图，它是西雅图电力公司；在亚特兰大，它是乔治亚电力公司，至今仍是亚特兰大的电力公司，当时就是它在运营火车，因为这两项业务在当时配合得非常好。如果你想为一个
neighborhood, you could also run a train line out to that neighborhood and kill two birds with one stone. So it was pretty common for power companies to have a subway side hustle, and in the case of Pacific Electric, that side hustle was all in the interest of making money on real estate. Here's how it worked. Henry Huntington bought up a bunch of farmland. He turned that farmland into suburbs, and then he made those suburbs desirable and valuable by connecting them with, you guessed it, trains.
社区通电，你也可以顺便修一条火车线路到那个社区，一举两得。所以电力公司拥有地铁作为副业是很常见的，而在太平洋电气公司的案例中，这个副业完全是为了在房地产上赚钱。它是这样运作的：亨利·亨廷顿买下了一大片农田，把农田变成了郊区，然后通过连接这些郊区（你猜对了）的火车，使这些郊区变得令人向往且价值连城。
All through the early 20th century, Pacific Electric just kept going like this. Henry Huntington would buy a plant, run a train through it, sell that land for profit, and then do it all over again. And as the red car routes got longer, LA's sprawling suburbs started to take shape, even before most Angelenos owned a car. If you look at the maps of the old Pacific Electric system, you can tie that to the great streets of LA. Santa Monica Boulevard and Sunset Boulevard had trains at one time, and all of the neighborhoods that were built up around there were designed around the train.
整个20世纪初，太平洋电气公司就这样一直运作下去。亨利·亨廷顿会买下一块地，修一条火车线路穿过它，卖掉那块地获利，然后再重复一遍。随着“红车”路线越来越长，洛杉矶蔓延的郊区开始成形，甚至在大多数洛杉矶人拥有汽车之前就是如此。如果你看看旧太平洋电气系统的地图，你可以把它与洛杉矶的大街联系起来。圣莫尼卡大道和日落大道曾经都有火车，围绕那里建立的所有社区都是围绕火车设计的。
Even places deep into the suburbs like San Marino, right? These are places that were originally designed to be accessed via train. This may sound like an alternate better version of LA that could have been a transit friendly Los Angeles, one in which Jake never had to languish behind that Jeep with too many bumper stickers on the freeway. But the people actually using the red car didn't feel that way.
即使是深入郊区的地方，比如圣马力诺，对吧？这些地方最初就是设计成通过火车进入的。这听起来可能是一个更好的洛杉矶替代版本，一个对交通友好的洛杉矶，一个杰克永远不必在高速公路上被困在那辆贴满保险杠贴纸的吉普车后面的洛杉矶。但真正使用“红车”的人并不这么觉得。
Even though it went to a lot of places people wanted to go, the cracks began to show by the 1920s. The trains were falling into disrepair. And that's because the red car itself didn't make money. It was just a convenient way to inflate property values. Henry Huntington didn't care about how well it was running. So once the real estate ventures began to run out of cheap land, there was no reason to keep running good passenger service.
尽管它去了很多人们想去的地方，但到了20世纪20年代，裂痕开始显现。火车开始年久失修。这是因为“红车”本身并不赚钱。它只是提高房地产价值的一种便捷手段。亨利·亨廷顿并不关心它运行得如何。所以一旦房地产项目开始耗尽廉价土地，就没有理由继续提供良好的客运服务了。
And for a 20-year period between like 1925 and World War II, the Pacific Electric's passenger services were bleeding money because the company didn't particularly care, and they were making their real money by transporting freight and building homes. The final blow came with the rise of cars, which shared space with the street trolleys and slowed them down even more. Eventually, Pacific Electric was losing so much money that the company had to ask for public dollars to fund infrastructure upgrades. But by this time, Angelino's absolutely
在1925年到二战之间的20年里，太平洋电气的客运服务一直在亏损，因为公司并不特别在意，他们真正的钱是通过运输货物和建造房屋赚来的。最后一击来自于汽车的兴起，汽车与有轨电车共享道路，使它们的速度变得更慢。最终，太平洋电气亏损严重，不得不向公共资金寻求基础设施升级。但到那时，洛杉矶人已经彻底
hated Pacific Electric. And the red car. The City Council of Los Angeles said, we're not doing this because the public doesn't want it. Twenty years of really crummy service and their reputation of commercial ruthlessness had really soured the public on public transport as an institution. The result of all this is that LA became the car-centric city, even if it does have a modest regional subway today.
讨厌太平洋电气和“红车”了。洛杉矶市议会说，我们不这样做，因为公众不想要它。20年来糟糕的服务和他们商业无情的名声，确实让公众对公共交通这一机构感到厌恶。这一切的结果是，洛杉矶成为了以汽车为中心的城市，即使它今天拥有一个适度的区域地铁。
As for the red car, it limped along through the 1940s and 50s until finally in 1961 it ran for the last time. Some of the trolley cars got shipped abroad to live a second life, but most of them were sold for scrap. This is in contrast to another North American city on our list, which today has a booming public transit system, a city whose subways aren't lost per se, but are completely painfully hobbled by good old-fashioned bureaucracy. One of the most famous transit systems in the U.S. is, of course, the New York City subway.
至于“红车”，它在20世纪40年代和50年代步履蹒跚，直到1961年最后一次运行。一些电车被运往国外开启了第二次生命，但大多数被当作废铁卖掉了。这与我们名单上的另一个北美城市形成了鲜明对比，该城市今天拥有蓬勃发展的公共交通系统，一个地铁系统并非“失落”，而是被老派官僚主义完全且痛苦地束缚住了。美国最著名的交通系统之一，当然是纽约地铁。
New York's Metropolitan Transit Authority, or MTA, has the largest and busiest subway system on the continent. New Yorkers love it. They hate it. They love to hate it. They love to love it. And whether you love it or hate it, you ride the subway. The subway is indispensable.
纽约大都会运输署（MTA）拥有北美最大、最繁忙的地铁系统。纽约人爱它，恨它。他们爱恨交加。无论你爱它还是恨它，你都要坐地铁。地铁是不可或缺的。
It's something that needs to be there. And New York cannot function without a working subway. By and large, for over a century, New York's transit system has stood as a shining example of what works. It's the one place where you're usually better off taking the train as opposed to driving to get from point A to point B. A big reason for this success
它是必须存在的东西。没有正常运行的地铁，纽约就无法运转。总的来说，一个多世纪以来，纽约的交通系统一直是行之有效的典范。它是你从A点到B点通常坐火车比开车更好的地方。这种成功的一个重要原因
is that most of New York's subway system was built pretty quickly and efficiently. The first New York subway line started getting built in the year 1900, and by the time it opened in 1904, the train ran from City Hall downtown all the way to Harlem. By 1940, the New York subway system had over 400 stations. But by the mid-20th century, after going through a series of mergers, financial challenges, and a decline in ridership, all that construction basically ground to a halt. Since 1950, New York has added only 30 more stations.
是纽约的大部分地铁系统建设得相当迅速且高效。第一条纽约地铁线路始建于1900年，到1904年开通时，火车从市中心的市政厅一直开到了哈莱姆区。到1940年，纽约地铁系统拥有超过400个车站。但到了20世纪中叶，在经历了一系列合并、财务挑战和客流量下降后，所有这些建设基本上陷入了停滞。自1950年以来，纽约仅增加了30个车站。
And as of today, the city has been trying to finish just one additional subway line, the Second Avenue subway, for almost 100 years. They were promising to build the Second Avenue subway in the 1930s. They would tear down this elevated line, which was ugly, old, noisy, kind of an eyesore, and replace it with a clean, fast underground subway line. That didn't happen.
直到今天，该市一直在试图完成仅一条额外的地铁线路——第二大道地铁，已经快100年了。他们早在20世纪30年代就承诺要修建第二大道地铁。他们会拆除这条高架线路，它又丑、又老、又吵，有点碍眼，并用一条干净、快速的地下地铁线取而代之。那并没有发生。
And for the bulk of the 20th century, World War II, the Civil Rights Movement, Apollo 11, the Berlin Wall, 9-11, they still hadn't finished the Second Avenue subway. What's the current status of the Second Avenue subway? The Second Avenue subway has a mile and three quarters right now and they promised 10 So neighborhoods like Spanish Harlem the East Village the Lower East Side They were promised this really great service to the East Side for decades And it still hasn't happened yet and it became a kind of municipal joke among New Yorkers such that there are
在20世纪的大部分时间里，二战、民权运动、阿波罗11号、柏林墙、9·11事件都过去了，他们仍然没有完成第二大道地铁。第二大道地铁目前的状况如何？第二大道地铁现在只有1.75英里，而他们承诺的是10英里。所以像西班牙哈莱姆区、东村、下东区这样的社区，几十年来一直被承诺提供这种非常好的东区服务。但它至今仍未实现，这成了纽约人之间的一种市政笑话，以至于有
And it became a kind of municipal joke among New Yorkers, such that there are snippets on Mad Men, where people are shopping for apartments on Second Avenue, and the real estate agent is saying, oh, this is on Second Avenue. When the Second Avenue subway gets here, you'll make a mint. And I'm thinking to myself, aha, I get the joke. This thing is set in 1965. Got it. joke, this thing is set in 1965. Got it. After almost a hundred years of the second Avenue subway planning, all that New York's got to show for it are three new stations on the Upper East Side, which were finished in 2017. It's the perfect example of a system that is so close to having it all. It could be fast, frequent, reliable,
以至于有《广告狂人》里的片段，人们在第二大道买公寓，房地产经纪人说，哦，这在第二大道。当第二大道地铁通车时，你会发大财的。我心想，啊哈，我懂这个梗。这东西设定在1965年。明白了。在近百年的第二大道地铁规划后，纽约所能展示的只有2017年完工的上东区三个新车站。这是一个如此接近拥有一切的系统的完美例子。它本可以是快速、频繁、可靠、
and widespread if it weren't for a political gridlock that sets it apart from functional systems all over the world. Being able to do these kinds of things at scale requires extremely patient planning at the front end, but once you make a decision to go, you do things as quickly as possible. So, if you think about a place like Madrid, they built subways in bulk for decades. And so they got very good at it. They have all of this institutional knowledge and they have the capacity to do this within their own bureaucracy.
且广泛的，如果不是因为政治僵局使它与世界各地的功能性系统区分开来的话。能够大规模地做这些事情需要在前端进行极其耐心的规划，但一旦你决定行动，就要尽可能快地完成。所以，如果你想到像马德里这样的地方，他们几十年来大规模地修建地铁。所以他们非常擅长。他们拥有所有这些机构知识，并且有能力在自己的官僚机构内完成这些工作。
That's not really the case in the United States. Instead, you have a million different changes once the plans get released in New York. In other words, Madrid makes a plan and moves forward with it quickly at large scale. But that's not the case with New York because even if the MTA started out with the best plan imaginable, there's often too many factors slowing things down.
在美国情况并非如此。相反，在纽约，一旦计划发布，就会有无数不同的变动。换句话说，马德里制定计划并大规模地迅速推进。但纽约并非如此，因为即使MTA从最完美的计划开始，也往往有太多的因素拖慢了进度。
For one, there are too many cooks in the kitchen. Decisions about subway system have to be made jointly between the mayor, the governor, and various government consultants and contractors, who all have to agree on the same plan. Everyone wants to have their two cents, even though everyone agrees that this subway line really needs to get built. Or at least there's a political consensus that these subway lines need to get built. Or at least there's a political consensus that these subway lines need to get built. To make matters worse, doing things so slowly is expensive. By building piecemeal instead of all at once, the MTA loses out on the economies of scale. Each station ends up being built to its own unique blueprint rather than a standardized
首先，参与的人太多了。关于地铁系统的决定必须由市长、州长以及各种政府顾问和承包商共同做出，他们都必须同意同一个计划。每个人都想发表自己的意见，尽管每个人都同意这条地铁线确实需要修建。或者至少在政治上达成了一致，认为这些地铁线需要修建。更糟糕的是，做事如此缓慢是昂贵的。通过零敲碎打而不是一次性完成，MTA失去了规模经济。每个车站最终都是按照自己独特的蓝图建造的，而不是标准化的
layout. And instead of having experts on staff, the MTA hires different sets of contracts on a per-project basis, which means that a mile of subway track in New York costs six times more than in Berlin or Tokyo. It's just too expensive and too slow to grow in the way that riders need it to. The next city on our list is Atlanta, Georgia. There was a time when Atlanta was so close to having a really amazing subway system, but ultimately it was derailed by the same force that had tanked initiatives in many,
布局。而且MTA不是聘请专家作为员工，而是按项目聘请不同的承包商，这意味着纽约一英里的地铁轨道成本是柏林或东京的六倍。它太昂贵、太缓慢，无法以乘客需要的方式增长。我们名单上的下一个城市是佐治亚州亚特兰大。曾经有一段时间，亚特兰大非常接近拥有一个真正令人惊叹的地铁系统，但最终它被同样的力量所破坏，这种力量在许多
many other North American cities. And that is plain old racism. I don't think it's an accident that the big turn against public transport coincided with the period of desegregation. There's no other way to slice it. Back in the 1950s, postwar Atlanta was booming. Along with other American cities in the Sun Belt, Atlanta experienced a rise in population after World War II. Cheap and widespread air conditioning brought a solution to the unbearably hot summers,
其他北美城市中也扼杀了倡议。那就是赤裸裸的种族主义。我不认为公共交通的大转折与废除种族隔离时期同时发生是一个巧合。没有别的解释。回到20世纪50年代，战后的亚特兰大正在蓬勃发展。与其他阳光地带的美国城市一样，亚特兰大在二战后经历了人口增长。廉价且普及的空调为难以忍受的炎热夏天提供了解决方案，
and many manufacturing jobs were moving to cities in the South. Atlanta wasn't just booming, though. It was proud. As the most racially progressive city in the former Confederacy, Atlanta called itself the city too busy to hate. As people flooded into Atlanta, city planners decided to build a new expressway so all these people could move around the city. But a lot of residents opposed the highway construction. There was an Atlanta anti-highway movement that sprung up in the 1950s, along with calls to build a new state-of-the-art Atlanta Metro. And the fact was that the anti-freeway and pro-metro movement had both black and white supporters,
许多制造业工作岗位正在向南方城市转移。然而，亚特兰大不仅在蓬勃发展，它还很自豪。作为前邦联中最具种族进步性的城市，亚特兰大自称为“太忙而无暇仇恨的城市”。随着人们涌入亚特兰大，城市规划者决定修建一条新的高速公路，以便所有人都能在城市中穿行。但许多居民反对高速公路建设。20世纪50年代出现了一个亚特兰大反高速公路运动，同时还有修建新的最先进的亚特兰大地铁的呼声。事实上，反高速公路和支持地铁运动都有黑人和白人支持者，
and in particular the kinds of rich white folk who were opposing the freeway network were on board with this. Across racial lines, people wanted this subway. That is, until desegregation. When Atlanta's buses were desegregated in 1959, many white people, even in the city too busy to hate, stopped taking the bus. So much public transport cut down during the era of desegregation. Atlanta's bus ridership dropped by double digits when the buses were desegregated. It turns out many white people only wanted public transportation
特别是那些反对高速公路网的富裕白人也支持这一点。跨越种族界限，人们想要这条地铁。直到废除种族隔离。当亚特兰大的公共汽车在1959年废除种族隔离时，许多白人，即使是在那个“太忙而无暇仇恨的城市”，也停止乘坐公共汽车。在废除种族隔离时代，公共交通大幅削减。当公共汽车废除种族隔离时，亚特兰大的公共汽车客流量下降了两位数。事实证明，许多白人只想要公共交通，
so long as they didn't have to share it with black people. Before the metro could actually be built, white support petered out and the idea was dead in the water. The lesson being that ultimately it doesn't matter if the subway you're building is fast, frequent, reliable, and goes everywhere people want to go if half the population refuses to use it. Atlanta's not the only place where this happened. You also see this in Detroit, where the northern suburbs of Detroit fought for decades to not take $600
只要他们不必与黑人共享。在地铁真正建成之前，白人的支持就逐渐消失了，这个想法也就胎死腹中。教训是，最终，如果你修建的地铁是快速、频繁、可靠且能到达人们想去的任何地方，但如果一半的人口拒绝使用它，那也无济于事。亚特兰大并不是唯一发生这种情况的地方。你在底特律也能看到这一点，底特律的北部郊区几十年来一直反对接受6亿美元的
million in federal money to build a subway, because there was a lot of fear in the northern suburbs of Detroit to having black people come into these otherwise white neighborhoods. Even in places like, say, the San Francisco Bay area, you have a major cut down of the BART system due to racism in San Mateo County, which is immediately to the south of San Francisco. San Mateo County, by the way, was 96% white in the 1960s when this was all happening. And the people that most vocally resisted BART
联邦资金来修建地铁，因为底特律北部郊区非常担心黑人进入这些原本是白人的社区。即使在像旧金山湾区这样的地方，由于圣马特奥县（位于旧金山正南）的种族主义，BART系统也遭到了重大削减。顺便说一句，在20世纪60年代这一切发生时，圣马特奥县96%是白人。而那些最强烈抵制BART的人
very much wanted to keep it that way. Which meant that the lines beneath Geary Boulevard across the Golden Gate Bridge into Marin County, as well as the line to Palo Alto, where Stanford is, both got canceled because there was no money. For any city to have a comprehensive and successful public transportation network, it is so important that the communities that make it up
非常想保持这种状态。这意味着盖里大道下方、穿过金门大桥进入马林县的线路，以及通往斯坦福大学所在的帕洛阿尔托的线路，都因为没有钱而被取消了。对于任何城市来说，要拥有一个全面且成功的公共交通网络，至关重要的是组成它的社区
are willing to fund it and use it. So every time a white suburban neighborhood bows out of a subway line, it shakes the very foundation of the city's entire public transit. And too often, the result is a much-scaled back system that can't go everywhere people want to go. After the break, how the United States turned away from public transit and instead watched its cities become crisscrossed with highways, and how Canada learned from our mistakes. Subway systems across North America have each struggled in their own way to meet the four benchmarks of solid public transportation.
愿意资助并使用它。所以每当一个白人郊区社区退出一条地铁线路时，它就会动摇整个城市公共交通的基础。而结果往往是一个规模大幅缩减的系统，无法到达人们想去的每一个地方。休息之后，美国是如何背离公共交通，转而看着其城市被高速公路纵横交错，以及加拿大是如何从我们的错误中吸取教训的。北美各地的地铁系统都以各自的方式努力达到稳健公共交通的四个基准。
But there's one law that impacted every U.S. city and gave cars an advantage over public transportation that continues to this day. The Federal Eight Highway Act of 1956 changed the game. Coming off the tale of World War II, the U.S. government believed that America needed big roads spanning the country in order to move troops should there be a ground invasion in the future. So, under the act, the government subsidized almost the entire cost of building new highways. We never did have that ground invasion,
但有一项法律影响了每一个美国城市，并赋予了汽车相对于公共交通的优势，这种优势一直持续到今天。1956年的《联邦援助公路法》改变了游戏规则。二战结束后，美国政府认为美国需要横跨全国的大型道路，以便在未来发生地面入侵时调动军队。因此，根据该法案，政府补贴了修建新高速公路几乎全部的成本。我们从未经历过那次地面入侵，
but we're still dealing with the consequences of the act. For one, it did provide an easy way to move between cities, but it also incentivized cities and states to literally bulldoze many black neighborhoods to make way for all the new development. It also happens to be one reason that America really loves cars. But there's a notable place in North America where the Federal Aid Highway Act didn't
但我们仍在处理该法案的后果。首先，它确实提供了一种城市间移动的便捷方式，但它也激励了城市和州为了给所有新开发项目让路，而直接推平了许多黑人社区。这也是美国人非常喜欢汽车的一个原因。但在北美有一个显著的地方，《联邦援助公路法》并不
apply, and that would be Canada. As highways went up like crazy in post-war America, Canadian cities saw a cautionary tale in all this. So when Seattle built highways in the 1950s, Vancouver, just across the border, decided to do things differently. I want to talk about Canadian cities and how they kind of had the sort of benefit of seeing what highways did when they were planning. Can you talk about that a little bit? So Vancouver got started late on its freeway system. And for a point of comparison, Seattle got started with its freeway building extravaganza
适用，那就是加拿大。当战后美国的高速公路疯狂兴起时，加拿大城市从中看到了一个警示故事。所以当西雅图在20世纪50年代修建高速公路时，边境对面的温哥华决定采取不同的做法。我想谈谈加拿大城市，以及他们在规划时如何从高速公路的后果中获益。你能谈谈这个吗？温哥华的高速公路系统起步较晚。作为一个对比，西雅图在二战后开始了它的高速公路建设狂潮。
after World War II. Vancouver didn't really get started with the planning process until the 60s. So there was about a 10 to 20 year gap in there where Vancouver could see the results happening in its neighbor three hours to the south. And what they found was they didn't like those results. They didn't like the smog, they didn't like the pollution.
温哥华直到60年代才真正开始规划过程。所以中间有大约10到20年的差距，温哥华可以看到其南部三小时车程的邻居所发生的结果。他们发现他们不喜欢那些结果。他们不喜欢雾霾，不喜欢污染。
And further afield, they saw the results in Los Angeles. There was a strong political contingent that used the specter of Vancouver turning into the next LA that ultimately defeated all of the freeway plans for Greater Vancouver. Wow. And so what did they end up with? Well, then they ended up with the famous SkyTrain, which was the product of a weird confluence of circumstances.
放眼更远的地方，他们看到了洛杉矶的结果。有一个强大的政治派别利用温哥华变成下一个洛杉矶的阴影，最终否决了所有大温哥华地区的高速公路计划。哇。那么他们最终得到了什么？好吧，他们最终得到了著名的“天车”（SkyTrain），这是奇怪的情况汇合的产物。
Vancouver bid and won a World's Fair for 1986, and it was a World's Fair about transport. Now, Vancouver didn't have anything special in their transport department. And so the provincial authorities had to go scrambling to find a transport system that they could build between 1980 and 1986. Without really any other options, Vancouver asked the government of Canada for help building a train system in their city before the big event. And basically the Canadian government said yes, but under one condition. They planned to use the World's Fair as a product placement for a Canadian railcar company that had been
温哥华申办并赢得了1986年世博会，那是一届关于交通的世博会。当时，温哥华的交通部门并没有什么特别之处。因此，省政府不得不匆忙寻找一个可以在1980年到1986年之间建造的交通系统。在没有其他选择的情况下，温哥华在盛会前向加拿大政府寻求帮助，在他们的城市修建火车系统。基本上，加拿大政府同意了，但有一个条件。他们计划利用世博会作为一家加拿大铁路车辆公司的产品植入，该公司已经
floundering for years. And the government of Canada decided that this was a perfect opportunity to bail out a failing rail car manufacturer that was owned by the province of Ontario. The province of Ontario had developed this automated subway system that nobody wanted to buy. As a result, the government of Canada said, fine, we will fund your World's Fair, we will fund your construction of your subway,
挣扎多年了。加拿大政府认为这是一个拯救一家由安大略省拥有的失败铁路车辆制造商的绝佳机会。安大略省开发了这个没人想买的自动化地铁系统。结果，加拿大政府说，好吧，我们将资助你们的世博会，我们将资助你们地铁的建设，
but you must use this technology. Like the company is based in Ontario and not even the Toronto Transit Commission wanted to buy this thing. The new system was so hard to sell in part because it did have this one major drawback. It required non-standard components, which meant cities wouldn't be able to easily switch vendors down the line. Thankfully, it worked. And the SkyTrain is a huge success, but it had huge risks to what they were doing at the time.
但你们必须使用这项技术。就像这家公司总部在安大略省，甚至多伦多交通委员会都不想买这东西。新系统之所以难以推销，部分原因在于它确实有一个主要缺点。它需要非标准组件，这意味着城市以后无法轻易更换供应商。谢天谢地，它成功了。天车是一个巨大的成功，但它在当时所做的事情面临巨大的风险。
And all because they were trying to impress, you know, like, or fulfill this mandate of this transportation-based expo. Oh, yeah. So, could you describe the SkyTrain, like, how it works and, you know, what it looks like to be on it? So, the SkyTrain is an elevated how it works and, you know, what it looks like to be on it? So, the SkyTrain is an elevated, like the one you have in Chicago. The difference is its trains are shorter and it's fully automated.
这一切都是因为他们试图给人们留下深刻印象，或者完成这个基于交通的博览会的使命。哦，是的。那么，你能描述一下天车，它是如何运作的，以及坐在上面是什么感觉吗？所以，天车是一个高架系统，就像你在芝加哥看到的那样。不同之处在于它的列车更短，而且是全自动的。
Meaning the SkyTrain runs without a driver. Yeah. So, because they're automated, you can run frequent service all day. And as far as operating costs, this dramatically reduces them compared to having a manned system. How common is the automated system? Why doesn't everyone do that? Most modern subway lines can be designed with automation in mind, but it's very difficult to retrofit them to an existing subway system which was not designed without a driver. So in a place like Chicago or New York or Boston or for that matter Montreal or Toronto, it's really hard to convert a system from manual control to fully automated control.
这意味着天车没有司机。是的。所以，因为它们是自动化的，你可以全天提供频繁的服务。至于运营成本，与有人驾驶的系统相比，这大大降低了成本。自动化系统有多普遍？为什么不是每个人都这样做？大多数现代地铁线路在设计时都可以考虑到自动化，但要将它们改造为现有的、没有设计为无人驾驶的地铁系统是非常困难的。所以在芝加哥、纽约、波士顿，或者蒙特利尔或多伦多，将系统从手动控制转换为全自动控制确实很难。
In North America, Vancouver is really the best example of an automated system that works well. There are some in North America which were designed for partial automation like Bard in San Francisco or the Washington Metro. But because these ancient systems haven't always been maintained the right way, a lot of them are still stuck on manual control.
在北美，温哥华确实是运行良好的自动化系统的最佳例子。北美有一些设计用于部分自动化的系统，比如旧金山的BART或华盛顿地铁。但由于这些古老的系统并不总是以正确的方式维护，其中许多仍然停留在手动控制上。
Interesting. Jake, this is such a fascinating book. I love it so much. I really enjoy talking with you. I really appreciate it. It was a pleasure. Jake's book is called The Lost Subways of North America, a cartographic guide to the past, present, and what might have been. Not only will you find great stories about the subways of North America, it also features
有趣。杰克，这是一本如此引人入胜的书。我非常喜欢它。我真的很喜欢和你交谈。我非常感激。这是我的荣幸。杰克的书名为《北美的失落地铁：过去、现在和可能性的制图指南》。你不仅会发现关于北美地铁的精彩故事，它还收录了
beautiful transit maps that Jake illustrated himself. I had so much fun looking at these maps, so make sure you check it out too. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sarah Bake, edited by Kelly Prime, music by Swan Real, mix and sound design by Ezek Ben Amad Farid. Kathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Colestead is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Perube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martín González, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne Leigh, Lajim Adhan, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Nina Pazak, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars.
杰克亲自绘制的精美交通地图。我在看这些地图时玩得很开心，所以一定要去看看。本周的《99% Invisible》由莎拉·贝克制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，混音和声音设计由埃泽克·本·阿马德·法里德完成。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉吉姆·阿德汉、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、尼娜·帕扎克、乔·罗森伯格，以及我，罗曼·马斯。
The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, and beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. Home to the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go,
99% Invisible的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。这里是奥克兰根足球俱乐部的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。其他球队可能会来来去去，
but the Roots are Oakland first, always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. There are like three or 4, people talking about architecture and talking about the power broker and talking about the stories on the show and all kinds of things, music, movies, everything. It's a nice group over there. Check it out.
但根队永远是奥克兰第一。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们新的Discord服务器。那里有三四千人在讨论建筑、讨论《权力掮客》、讨论节目中的故事以及各种各样的事情，音乐、电影，什么都有。那是一个很好的群体。去看看吧。
There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在99PI.org上有该链接以及99PI的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。